how do you clean a Tesla Model why well
there's one secret I'm going to tell you
at the end first of all you're gonna
need to start with some high quality
soap then you're going to need to throw
that into your foam Cannon and set it up
with your Karcher pressure cleaner you
need a two bucket wash system and a dirt
trap don't forget about your wheel brush
and of course your woolly mammoth
microfiber towel first of all you want
to give it a quick spray and then you
want to switch over to the foam Cannon
you want a foam Cannon the entire car so
it's easier to scrub off all the dirt
and bugs the secret in this video is
that you're going to need a little furry
mitt this is the best thing you can
clean your car with and it will
guarantee you don't scratch it as long
as you use the two bucket system a Good
Wheel brush is also going to be padded
on all sides so that means you can go to
town on your wheels make sure you get
into every Groove and don't damage any
of your wheels finally you're going to
get your woolly mammoth back out and
clean that entire car quickly and
seamlessly that's it that's how you
clean your Tesla Model y